[音楽]
最近のグミは
多すぎや皆さんグミというものご存知
でしょうかあのお菓子の一種なんですけど
もこうなんかゼラチン状に固めたいたって
シンプルなお菓子洗って歯ごたえもある色
も綺麗もう大人気のお菓子グミというもの
があるんですけれどもこれ結構昔になんか
売ってるグミ集めて混ぜたことがあるん
ですよ何で味になるんだろうなと思って
その時の動画のグミの数見てみこれ売れる
のかな売れてるか知らないんですけど
気づいたらものすごい量のグミが販売され
てて結構いろんなコンビニ回って集めた
つもりだったんですけども当時これぐらい
の量だったんですよグミわりとコンビニと
かでかき集めても今や見てこれ
増えたんですここ45年で実は知らんけど
なんか海外のなんかその留学生みたいな子
たちもいてあなたたちは韓国ね
USかなあなたたちのUSあなたは
モロッコですねあなたはベネズエラ
いろんな海外のグミとかがこう日本の国
市場に参入してきたりそもそもグミという
ものがすごい人気になってきててなんか
今年5年で日本で発売されてるグミの量も
かなり増えたとおかしい大好き人間の
初めての社長は思ったわけですよそこで僕
ん家の近くにあるコンビニでグミかき集め
てみたらこんなになりましたおいマジで
多いもう絶対45年前こんなになかった
本当に増えたんですよグミの数がなんか
色んなドミノ何なんかミミズみたいなグミ
だったりなんかこう哺乳瓶みたいなグミも
あるし地球グミとかもね結構なんかその
グミ教会に火をつけた大事なんですよ責任
取れまあかなり色んな国があるんですけど
も合計何個数えてみよう
123456789よし
くそ忘れた
真剣に数えよう
[音楽]
12345622824125126126
おかおかしいってそんなにワイワイ人だっ
た時代にグミはなかったあの頃の動画で
この限界だと相当グミの数が増えすぎたん
でこれ混ぜたらかなりやばいものができる
んじゃないかと彼らいろんな味とが色んな
アレンジ色んな形して試行錯誤して工夫し
て組み換えに参入してきたわけなんです
けども彼らがたどり着きたいところは1
箇所グミの王様を彼らはグミの王様グミ界
のキングを目指してこの味って決められて
パッケージもあのみんな考えて世に出さ
れるわけなんですけども彼らグミたちが
たどり着く先はどこなのか実際に今日作っ
てみたいと思いますというわけで今日の
企画は全てのグミをまとめて
史上最強のグミを作ってみようです
昔もやったけども次元が違うで果たして何
味になるのでしょうか
はいというわけで早速グミを混ぜていく
わけなんですけどもただ混ぜるわけじゃ
ありませんこちら
餅つきを準備しました相当な量の軍になる
と思うんで頑張ってこうグミをここに入れ
てってついてこねくり回してグミにしたい
と思いますそして今回私1人でグミを
混ぜるわけではありませんなんとなんと
ですねあの超人気お笑い芸人クールポコ
さんにお越しいただいておりますどうぞ
はいよろしくお願いしますよしやって
いこうかはい
健介世の中ねどんな男がいるって
モテようとして女の子にパスタ作ってた男
がいたんですよ
男は黙って男と料理でもなんでもないよ
よろしくお願いします
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
はいえーお二人には帰ってもらいましたと
いうわけで早速全部混ぜていきたいと思い
ます
魔剣グミ
メジャーな中のメジャー
駄菓子屋とかで売ってるやつですね
チョキでしたこれでじゃんけんしてる人見
たことないないただきます
おいしいシンプルな味ですねこれだけ入れ
たいと思います
果汁グミにレモン僕いつも果汁グミ食べる
時
ブドウなんでレモンあんまり食べないん
ですいただきますうん
酸っぱいちゃんと酸っぱいなすごいよ栄養
の食品でねビタミンC入ってて2粒で1日
分のビタミンC取れるってそういう何か
プラスのグミってちょっと流行ってますよ
ね和泉
葡萄よく食べますいただきます
うんいつもの味風味マスカット
ラリー
いただきますしっかり一度この香り果汁
グミ桃待って俺これさ120粒ぐらい食う
計算になるよまあいっか綺麗な色してます
いただきますなんか程よい甘さで食べ
やすいのみかんなんか高校の時よく食べて
たら思い出があるな色が可愛いいただき
ます10回みかんの味がします優しい小粒
今小粒などあるのか
いただきます
はまった真ん中に
弾力プラスすごく果汁グミ色んな
バリエーションツイン出してきてるこれ
つまり売れてるって事なんですよグミが
グミ業界で盛り上がってからこういう変化
球も出せるってことはきっとめっちゃ
丸っこいないただきます
[音楽]
弾力がすごいホルモンみたいバウンドする
カルボースターミックスついに来ました
ハリボーこれはもう海外といえばこれ
みたいな感じあるでしょうどうぞいろんな
味入ってるんですけどもはじめは1個で
いっかじゃあコーラみたいなやついただき
ますうんコーラの味にカニボケは色んな味
があるのでちょっと全種類入れます目玉
焼きハート可愛いクマコーラ
[音楽]
財布多分指輪ゴールドベアーズいろんな色
のクマさんが入ってますね赤いのいただき
ます
新台の味ってイメージしねおいしい普通に
質が高いとてもクオリティの高い海外の
グミです
ゴールドベアこれはなんかコンビニでよく
見るイメージ
可愛いいただきます
マジでうめえうめえから売れるんだろうな
ニックに4種類入れちゃいますハリボー
ハッピーコーラようやく1個ださっきの
コーラのやつしか入ってないですね最高に
うまいなるほど色がすごい可愛いいただき
ます
これは苦手カリブをゴーストリーグミーズ
絶対ハロウィンの売れ残りの外国の匂い
雑なハロウィンのかぼちゃとかが入って
ますね
魔女の帽子全種類入れときますペタグー
グミコーラペタググミよく見るけど食べた
ことはないですねおー見た目が食パンの
あの上の止めるやつみたいいただきます
うまい
弾力があってとっても美味しいですね
ペチャグにピーチおーめっちゃ色が綺麗
いただきます
ピーチペタググミメロンソーダ
エキゾチックな色してますねいただきます
ガチなメロンで忠実メロンソーダという
よりしっかりメロンの味がしました
ソフトグミとかハードグミとかグミの
片瀬棚によってもなんか人気が違いますよ
ねどうなっちゃうんだろう全部混ぜたら
ピレグミプレミアムスパークリングそんな
のあるんだいちご味っぽいですね
かなりいいポジションにいますねとっても
美味しいですし俺好きですいただきます
すごい
果実の
ジュレジュレが
ピルグリグレープ
いつもの味
結構やばいですすごい量の砂糖取ってんだ
多分なんか普通にも冷や汗かいてきました
今代謝が良くなってきたのかな体にいい
じゃんグミくれぐれマスカット
食感がいいねくれぐれプレミアムみかん
かわいい
プレミアムの中の濃厚なこのあの
肉
ジュレリングソーダーズ3色入っとる3つ
の味で構成されてますねこれメロンソーダ
グレープソンのパインソーダ終わったどれ
か1つで許してくださいメロンいただき
ます
甘酸っぱい味がしますクリリング3色の色
で構成されてるわ3つの味ですねこれ青
りんごぶどうもも終わった
桃だけで勘弁してくださいいただきます
結構控えめな味でグミ初心者には多分食べ
やすいやつだと思いますピレグミ梅味の
ピクミがあるんですねすごいいただきます
あ
酸っぱい好きな人は好きそうピレグミ
レモンなんかレモンのイメージがあります
ね
スパイシーチキン長野県シャイン
マスカットグミ
綺麗な色してますねいただきます
オーガニック
夕張メロングミ美しいオレンジいただき
ます北海道を感じます
こらこれはもうハードグミの代表作という
か
噛み応えがすごいんですよいただきます
5時間かかる以下同文いただきます
顎が
めっちゃ顎使いすぎて多分全部やった頃に
俺裏拳になってそうですね非常に顎が使え
ます
結構限界近いかもしれません結構当分的な
ヤバさが来てますね頑張りますピュアル
グミぶどう見た目めっちゃ好きいただき
ます
あ柔らかいこれぐらいだったら顎に優しく
て俺が好きピュアルグミンりんごいただき
ますだんだん味がわかんなくなってきた
ピュアルグミいちご味はあるんですね
よくわかんない
すみません
もう食べれませんちょっと
量が多すぎましたねグミのちょっとなんか
[音楽]
あとどんぐらいあるんだろう結構入れまし
たけど全然まだあるわけでしょこれ多分
全部味見でも一粒ずつ食べてたら俺普通に
糖尿病になります絶対味見する必要はない
んですけどさすがに味は皆さんにお伝えし
たいのでなんとあの
有名な芸人さんたち再びお呼びしており
ますどうぞはいというわけでクールチア
ええと後輩の2人に来てもらいました
よろしくお願いします
[拍手]
[音楽]
もうこれじゃ危ないと思ったのでちょっと
食べて味の感想だけみんなに伝えてほしい
です2
種類入ってました
あらモードですね
純金ミックスジュース
可愛い見た目してますね
メロンクリームソーダメロン系キレイです
ねいただきます
明治を感じる
勢いで食ったけどさマジで無理だもう
薬なんかしびれとるもんコロナマスカット
はもう人気ですよとっても
ぶどうろ
いただきます
みかんのいちご味ポジションが多いですね
[音楽]
コロログレープ
ブドウみたい本当に安定このままそうだ色
は意外とそうだっぽくないですよね
神キング
味ありますわこれ3人で食べて1.5で
感想言うか味が3種類ありますエナジー
ソーダエナジーコーナーいただきます
種類あるのか3種類あります
[音楽]
また3種類ですいろんな種類入ってるの
多いなぶどうみかんいただきます
めっちゃ美味しいですこれ
めっちゃ美味しいですこれフルーツ
豆腐は何味のフルーツ豆腐だって
何でもないです
匂いすごいこれ
めっちゃマンゴーっぽい
うんおはようございますヒットチーネグミ
イタリアングレープこれも王道ですね
美味しい
粒に濃厚みかん3種類ありますねゆず
みかんようかん色はめっちゃ綺麗
YouTubeみかんいただきます
ねマスカットとブドウと巨峰みたいな感じ
ですかねマスカットいただきます
[音楽]
乳酸菌ヨーグルト体にいいやつも書いて
あるんですね5種類あるんでどれか1種類
だけ食べます色がめっちゃ綺麗です
いただきますよく
わかんないこれも5種類あるんで一粒だけ
食べます宝石みたいでめっちゃ綺麗
うん
宝石みたいにめっちゃ綺麗
シンプルなつむぐみこれも5種類か
カラフルです
[音楽]
何だよこのデゲパッケージコーラグミこれ
絶対海外だねこれは間違いなく海外だはい
どうも海外地獄のようなサイズしてますよ
これなんかめっちゃくちゃクオリティ高い
けど結構トロトロ系なんだでか
[音楽]
いっぱいいっぱいここに爆弾的な量ですわ
中になんかゼルみたいなの入ってて
おいしいしでもとっても多分最初に食えば
そうだグミ同じ系統ですね
うまい多分これ売れてると思う味でね俺を
察したこれ売れてる味だなっていうのは
はい
めっちゃ綺麗見た目なんか宝石みたいマジ
で
うんコンクリートより柔らかいだいぶ
分かりづらい
[笑い]
[音楽]
トウモロコシをいやきっとうまいいや多分
割と美味しかったの
すげえバックダンみたいなきましたけど
これ見た目おもろいねこれ
マジうまいわ多分これ
匂い嗅いでコンプ玉匂いするあうまい
うまいうまいうまいうまいあのーパッと見
手榴弾ですいただきます
甘いコンポタージュ
ちょっとこれきついなぁ同じシリーズの
ぶどうじでこれ単体で食う分に朝美味しい
んだけどさ見た目はすごい可愛いんですよ
すごいめっちゃブドウ再現されてます
いただきます
[音楽]
すごいな中身
岡山いちごがんばれこれでこれより苦しい
のはまだあるかもしれんいちご
可愛い
めっちゃイチゴですねトマトですねこれ
いただきますストロベリー
これやばくねこれやばいべってこれ今
すごい
爆発的なボリュームあったじゃんその時
タフグミだからこっからは顎使っていくよ
チューブ型ですね力強そう
固くておいしい
他国にホワイトタイガーさっきのホワイト
バージョンですねホワイトソーダ味です
タイガータイガーズタイガー
静かに3種類
です
いただきます
[音楽]
しずく型でかわいいですねうんしずく
ちゃんレモングミ同じ見た目の黄色
バージョンです
どこかで食べたことある味粒グミブロック
積んで遊べる超立体ブロックグリーンです
これ食べ物で遊ぶなぁ
[音楽]
矛盾してます
ね一生スポーツケーキだけ食べてほしい
今までの中身がドロドロしてます意外と
触ったらヌルヌルはしてないですね
しっかりブロックの形になってます
ちゃんとおいしいよ
現場からは以上ですロッドのフォーリー
グミ4Dシリーズも結構海外ですよねこれ
めっちゃ見た目可愛いしっかりクマです
[音楽]
またちょっと海外のどぎついの来ましたね
これ
めっちゃ見た目可愛いです中身は
[音楽]
梅干しです
海外ベビーボトルグリーン
やばいバリカ以外の顔しとるやん自分これ
バチバチの乳首やん
本当だいただきます
甘党の人は絶対好きGalaxyで見る
いろんな
惑星のグミがありますもう中身は白い
ストロベリーいちごの見た目をしており
ますオープン
見せてやるよいただきます
[音楽]
絆創膏のグミらしいです味が3色レモン
ジンジャエールコーラなんか匂いが絆創膏
みたいな匂い
嘘でしょ形がめっちゃ絆創膏です
うんわりとしっかりうまい
すごい
雪の結晶の形をしてます綺麗にはいという
わけで実は2時間ほど休憩しておりました
どうでも全然食いますよ
[音楽]
全然食えます
豚肉は幸せに肉球本当だ猫さんの肉球の
マークだ
ぷにぷにこんな物騒なのがあるんだ忍者
めし鋼だよこれ
プレッツェル
[音楽]
になってますねさけるチーズ的なやつです
かね
雪印
巨峰さっきのぶどう味です
ぶどう
いい意味でシャレモニー
角砂糖に
ラーメン
頑張ります
可愛いいちごケーキの形します
めっちゃショートケーキ
フィッツビッググミンゴツンとフニャン2
種類の食感がありますねこれ
[音楽]
いただきますいただきます
海外ゾーン来ましたトローリこれも本当
なんか最近聞くようになったなぁ
気持ち悪いこれ雲嫌いな人からすると泣く
よこれ
味は美味しいです
ミミズみたいきれいなミミズとろりザスク
イーグルス芋虫だ芋虫のがなんでこれ作っ
たやばくないこれ
芋虫と
蛾のグミですどういう神経してるん
でしょう
うん昆虫イラストがすごいよトロリスク
イーグルツイストイラストこれもう
芋虫なんですね
[拍手]
蛇のグミ3種類気持ち悪いいい意味で
ヘビーオクトパスタコのグミです
芋虫とろーりトラピックオーズ
綺麗なドーナツ
やばいよこれさ誰が喜んで使うのやっぱ
子供達とかやっぱ楽しいんじゃないの
ばっかでかい尻尾付きのネズミのグミです
マウストロリーサワーグミミックス
いろんな形のが入ってますカラフル
カラフルトロールシャークサメのグミ
かわいいシャークとろーりサワー
オクトパス
[拍手]
色がもうお世辞にも美味しそうとは言え
ません
[音楽]
透き通った見た目コムドットグミお金の
グミ
アバンティティーズ超弾力ハードグミガム
メーカーの何してんの
すごいの来たこれ
めっちゃシンプルですけどめっちゃ硬い
ですほぼ
ガムパスティーチ同じような見た目
ピーチアンパンマングミ
ディズニーのキャラクターがいっぱい
あ間違えたアンパンマンいただきますアン
パンマンSplatoon3グミイカ
タコスプラシューター自分に再生に下の
グミシャリッとしてそうな見た目してます
なしポケパに骨組み
丸いクラフト
グミオレンジ色みかんカチカチジクサーズ
カラフルカチカチドリンクカラフル
カチカチグミノは
[音楽]
結構感動するぐらいすごいデザイン
[拍手]
ブロックおいしいすごく脱出の番組紫
美味しい
黄色いカラフルおいしいハニーグミ六角形
うわかっこいい
たくさんのヒロアカのキャラ
グリーンパンうまい真心グミ
隕石
仮面色々入ってるうまい
全部入れ終わりましたー
[音楽]
一人だったら無理でした一粒一粒食べてる
んですけどそもそもの糖分量がやばすぎて
丸さんしても結構全員苦しいぐらいの分量
でしたそんなことなかったけどね
はいというわけで全てのグミを出し終える
ことができたので今からこのカラフルで
美しいグミたちを一つにまとめるために
ハンマーで叩いていきたいと思いますそれ
ではなさりよろしくお願いします
[音楽]
手伝って
危ない
[拍手]
あいよ
[音楽]
[拍手]
はいお願いします
[音楽]
無理ですね
無理だこれどんだけ叩いても叩いても変化
がないのでグミ結構
硬いんで
叩くだけだとくっつかないと思います
熱だちょっとドライヤーとかでちょっと
熱風を浴びてて温度を上げてグミを溶かし
ながらもうちょっと叩いていきたいと思い
ます
[音楽]
これ持った
これでやる意味ないわこの石臼みたいな
やつでやる必要ないのでこっちに移します
この量だったら多分入るしハンマーが無理
と分かった今ここでやる必要がまるでない
はい全て写し終わりました次からはこの中
でやっていきたいと思います
はい結構ドライヤー当ててみたんですけど
も割と溶けてきました中にはもう
原型をとどめていらっしゃらない方も
いらっしゃいますがまだなんか物によって
は完全に残ってるやつもありますねだいぶ
溶けてきました
混ぜながらもう少し熱を当ててみようと
思います
おーすごいすごいすごいすごい
[音楽]
[拍手]
はいというわけでドライヤーで続けたら
なんか固まりましたミルク
ティーまるでミルクティーのような色に
なってしまったが全体的に溶けちゃいます
中には多分スーパーハードグミとか解き
にくいと思うので完全には途切れないもの
のかなり溶けていますまんべんなくわりと
溶けてるはずでは
普通にするやつです
やばいやばいダメだ本当にダメですこれ
すごい名声というかなんか粘着するので指
突っ込むと普通にケトルに指突っ込んで
みたいな感じですねはいというわけで今は
まだドロドロなのでこれがグミという代物
ではありませんかなり熱いのでこれを冷蔵
庫に入れて冷やして固まって初めてグミの
完成です早速冷蔵庫入れてきます
やばいやばいやばいやばいおーイケメン
イケメン
[音楽]
はいというわけで1日おきました冷蔵庫に
入れて
完全に凍りましたおそらく日本国内に売っ
ている全てのグミをまとめた史上最強の
グミです
ドギツどぎついなこれもうなんか溶けきら
ないのとか結構ありますけどもまぁ
まんべんなく溶けているのかなと思います
でもなんか触り心地はちゃんとグミですわ
程よい弾力ですねやっぱハードグミとか
ソフトグミ色んなグミをこう混ぜ合わせた
結果なんかバランスよくいい感じの海に
なってます
そうかなかなか外れてカツカツ言うこと
ないけどな
いい感じハイチュウぐらいの感じだと思い
ますなんとか映したいんだよな
うーん絶対無理だね
[音楽]
よし取れた取れた取れた取れましたこれが
全てのグミが合わさった色ですねあんなに
カラフルだったのに今やカリカリ梅の種
いや見た目はとてもいいんです大事なのは
味ですいただきます
[音楽]
10円ガムのコーラ味の
味わった後のやつ
[音楽]
めっちゃ再現度高いわなんだっけあれ
なんか10円ガムなるじゃんね
フィリックスだこれですこれこれこの
10円ガムおいしいじゃないですかね
めっちゃ味わって噛んだ後のなんか味が
薄くなった後の10円ガムの味まじで
ドンピシャでそれですもうマジか結構苦労
して作っとるやん
辿り着くのは10円ガムかうーんそもそも
作るカレーで食いすぎたし結構もうグミは
いいかな
こんな食べれないなぁ